alright we're going to do a
walkthrough of pepper panic saga level 36
preparing to we the
two statues in the middle the border
there are two get a in the beginning
when
you're first starting out kinda hard to
understand how these work
so we thought we would you narration
over our video to give you an idea
the things that you should be thinking
about when we start we know
if you read the guide you know that we
wanna explode these two papers rate here
when we start out though we see that
there's not a lot of green peppers on
the board to grow the phone
and there's not really that many orange
although or under the little bit better
sovereignty for scissors moves from
things around at the bottom and see what
happens
a so
let's see we have
Greenland so
we have a decent mood with orange here
try that
it's an out something like purple is
is pretty big and we can move this green
went over and set the purple
thus far was the Orange's
aren't bad either so we this one book
orange or purple
re:
a here we could do your book this but
we're gonna
it will use up three big papers at the
time so this one's a little bit better
because only book this one its current
book this num
get that the chain reaction were
really look either or moved anyway
and you can kinda see in that example
there I'll
these the spot underneath the settees
can also
demoss searches but it's really hard to
keep these papers in place when you're
making a purchase low
right to know every red and purple we'll
have really either one of those colors
and readily available so this makes
another big movers here things fall into
place
in the twenty-first are playing this
game it's a little bit hard to think
about how
things fall and whether in and out
especially in the in a board where you
have obstructions because
things out this fall straight lines one
thing
move the always will look for in your
players that youth level is
this kinda match right here this was
gonna send a shock wave that's gonna hit
this that's right away
so you always wanna make these kinda
matters because they're much quicker
than growing the papers and
do it that way earlier
another one another shot live it up and
hit that their
I to nothing's changed totally only one
more hit
and its
the word a what's going to happen is
this purple peppers here now but it's
not gonna probably stay there till the
end
so what I'm gonna try to do is escrow
papers as fast
possible so that I can get a lecture
on the board
it are I mean obviously it's ideal we
could just simply grow
purple paper because you know that'll
happen but what happens as we're
making matches or exactly stays
rate we want it
I mean you can also use that to your
advantage because right now as you can
see
me that scream fall into place at the
we have some other remove their growth
this one every turn make a movie is
worth it and for helping
so no
really alone over here your purple here
in here
news and I saw this really wanna check
and see if you can get something that'll
a.m.
the process to do explode right away
here here we go so now we have a shock
wave that hit this green pepper
and when it does that are exploding the
it may move a but we have other green
peppers on the border expertise so this
is probably gonna be your best man
as i said im
we got really close with a purple number
you know that work go
always look around to see if you have a
shockwave though and
just try to make moves a little
grow as many papers as you can
it soon still have her boy over here
yeah orange appear
are reading or
you look like they would be the easiest
wills
limits these here
this is gonna actually dropped this
purple one out but with the US were
polled
now we're going to get up here the on
so I hope you have the hope that helps
to see how you are I think your way
through and just the
this is on those levels is hard to
figure out at first but it's not really
hard to complete
once you get the idea the
if you like I said if you read the guys
you understand that
what you're trying to do but hope this
video helps assure you that you know you
don't want to get stuck only trying to
grow the
but that's the ultimate goal you really
have to
just you reevaluate a 3-2 so I hope this
was helpful
on you have any questions leave a
comment when we get back right away
please take a second like us on Facebook
so that you can get our updating your
fee
and the we have lots in new stuff coming
all the time so we looked at the border
see me soon and
helping your much care